herzlich willkommen am montag das hier
das ist das ding auf das wir wahrlich
lange gewartet haben der korona plan der
bundesregierung der den freedom day
bringen soll den handel schon länger
gefordert diesen freedom day aber
offenbar wenigstens jetzt die hoffnung
auf den zwanzigster märz da steht drin
das was sie hier gerade sehen ist also
das papier und ich hier schon einmal
rüber weil ich will sehen ganz genau
zeigen was am mittwoch auf den tisch
kommt beim corona gipfel bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz das ist das
ding beschlussvorschlag steht hier noch
drin also das muss noch durchgewunken
werden das muss noch grünes licht
bekommen aber hier steht er eben drin
der freedom day und ganz wichtig ist
dass die experten auf die sich die
bundesregierung bezieht mittlerweile
eben davon ausgehen endlich endlich das
omikron eben nicht die schweren folgen
haben wird nicht mehr zu irgendwelchen
schweren belastungen in den
krankenhäusern führt und dafür gibt es
eben einen stufenplan dann ab jetzt und
der betrifft vor allen dingen zunächst
die privaten zusammenkünfte da steht
hier auf seite 3 also für geimpfte und
genießen am mensch das wurde aber
wirklich zeit dass das dann fällt und im
ersten schritt also das was dann ab
sofort gelten soll keine beschränkung
mehr wie mit wie vielen menschen man
sich im privaten treffen darf das der
erste schritt der dann ab sofort gelten
soll in einem zweiten schritt der
betrifft an den einzelhandel und vor
allen dingen die gastronomie
einzelhandel bundesweit für alle
personen ohne kontrollen auch das links
gefordert hier bei bild das soll dann
kommen und im zweiten schritt eben ab
dem vierten märz das ist also der erste
stichtag den sie sich merken sollen ab
dem vierten märz der zugang zur
gastronomie für geimpfte genesene und
alle anderen ohne tests und alles was
sonst noch so nervt also dieser zweite
schritt fürther märz das ist der erste
stichtag für sie das ist sozusagen der
kleine freedom day und der große freedom
day der soll dann folgen am zwanzigster
märz das ist das datum das hier drin
steht in dem beschlussvorschlag für den
corona gipfel am mittwoch also gas wird
der freedom day in deutschland so plant
es die bundesregierung mit den
ministerpräsidenten zu spät
möglicherweise darüber diskutieren wir
jetzt hier bei bild live
und wir schalten davor einmal zu ordnen
wir wollen wissen wie fühlen sie sich
jetzt gerade live in diesen sekunden
woraus kommt die freiheit die könnte
jetzt wirklich um die ecke stehen und
wir schalten so pierer ortmann sie ist
hier in der hauptstadt unterwegs und
gibt uns ein stimmungsbild ist gerade im
prenzlauer berg kira sag uns
frühlingstag sonnenschein und auch bald
die freiheit sie stets so nahe jetzt vor
uns
ja absolut man sieht es ja jetzt schon
wir stehen hier in der sonne und hinter
mir das café ist voll alle sonnen plätze
sind belegt und man sieht einfach man
hat es ja auch am wochenende schon
gemerkt die leute wollen wieder raus man
möchte wieder so ein bisschen freiheit
erleben und man möchte einfach wieder
das leben genießen was man ja in den
letzten zwei jahren gut man konnte ist
immer noch ein bisschen genießen aber
eben in mit deutlichen einschränkungen
und jetzt gerade am wochenende war ja
auch die ganze zeit schön es war schönes
wetter in ganz deutschland und das soll
jetzt auch die nächsten tage so
anbehalten und ja wie gesagt man sieht
dass die leute genießen ist einfach hier
im prenzlauer berg aber die anderen
cafés und auch schon fast alle voll und
wir haben uns auch schon mal umgehört
die ersten stimmungsbilder waren dann
auch ja jetzt jetzt muss es auch langsam
mal endlich wieder diese freiheiten
geben jetzt muss es auch endlich mal
wieder normal wirklich werden denn wir
haben es ja gerade schon gesagt hat dass
er gerade schon erklärt die zahlen sind
einfach mittlerweile so dass man eben
damit leben kann endlich ist das
entscheidende wort und möglicherweise zu
spät dank ihrer für die ersten eindrücke
nachdem diese gute nachricht eben heute
vormittag bei uns auf den tisch kam und
darüber wollen wir hier sprechen dem
studium mit unseren beiden tollen gästen
hier mit desiree nick herzlich
willkommen und eine hand soliris ebenso
herzlich willkommen ja die frage sofort
an euch zu spät weg mit dem corona
maßnahmen freedom day zwanzigster märz
müssen wir noch ein bisschen war ein so
boris johnson hat es ja vorgemacht und
es klappt sehr gut es gibt natürlich
jeden tag 2000 tote in deutschland auch
durch andere krankheiten die
vergänglichkeit des menschen kann man
damit nicht aufgeben ich hoffe nur dass
die
verschwörungstheoretiker sich das jetzt
nicht als erfolg ihrer aktionen
verbuchen und auf die eigene fahne
schreiben
man hätte es früher machen können aber
der deutsche hat natürlich ein großes
sicherheits bestreben sicherheit ist
auch eine illusion und es sind immer
noch nicht so viel geimpft wie in
england aber ich persönlich bin
überglücklich dass auch zusammen mit dem
frühjahr richtung ostern und da kann man
nur sagen endorphine euphorie sind dann
ein cocktail der hoffentlich das ganze
unter kontrolle behält nicht dass die
clubszene und so weiter dann denkt jetzt
soll es von heute auf morgen sein wie
früher ich glaube die persönliche
vorsicht ist nach wie vor geboten und
ich habe wohl auch verstanden maske muss
man weiterhin tragen so ist das wohl die
malerei oder nur ein bisschen erhalten
naja so schnell geht es dann doch nicht
aber trotzdem frühlingsgefühle kommen so
ein bisschen hoch und jetzt bei ihnen
auch frühlingsgefühle irgendwann ja die
ernüchterung das schon aber ich muss mal
ein bisschen wasser in den wein kippen
warum erst am 20 märz fragen sie das ist
einfach gesetzeslage alle corona
maßnahmen restlos entfallen gesetzlich
am 19 märz bis dahin sind sie befristet
das ist der § 28a desinfektion das heißt
jetzt sollten gar nicht anders konnten
wir können nicht anders im gegenteil sie
bleiben noch hinter dem gesetz zurück
denn ein bisschen was wollen sie
offenbar verlängern das können sie aber
gar nicht weil alles fällen flach auch
die masken pflicht sie bräuchten einen
wenn sie noch was erhalten wollen
bräuchten sie neues gesetz das neue
gesetz müsste auch die zustimmung der
fdp finden die sich eigentlich schon
entschlossen hat dem nicht mehr
zuzustimmen also dieses papier wird noch
eine menge diskussionen auslösen was am
ende übrig bleibt es ist ja auch nur die
rede von tief greift alle tief
greifenden maßnahmen was ist damit
gemeint ist die masken pflicht nicht
tiefgreifend ich finde schon ich bin
brillenträger dass auch dieses laufend
beschlagen ja wenn ich enthalten wenn
ich in ein geschäft gehen mich nervt die
maske wahnsinnig und die finde es könnte
auch reichen die leute zu ermahnen zu
ermahnen sie mögen bitte in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln der maske aufziehen und
dann ist es jedem einzelnen überlassen
ob er das tut oder nicht also eigentlich
ist der zwanzigste märz schon jetzt
gesetzlich der freedom de darüber wird
nicht geredet die politik fängt jetzt an
sich daraufhin zu zu orientieren weil
sie wissen daran kommen sie nicht vorbei
und das papier was die jetzt
aufgeschrieben haben ist reichlich
kompliziert sind tun nötigste es ist mal
wenig im leben noch sie bleiben sogar
noch hinter der gesetzeslage zurück weil
sie wollen nicht alles aufheben und nun
ist die frage macht die fdp um des
lieben koalitionsfriedens willen mit
noch die masken pflicht zu verlängern
würde neues gesetz erforderlich machen
oder nicht und in der koalition ist ja
muss man wissen geht ist nur dass
gesetzes fähig dem alle drei partner
zugestimmt haben wenn also einer nein
sagt geht es nicht das gibt noch lustige
diskussionen vor dem freedom ein und
jetzt erstmal was sie hinter den
kulissen auch was überhaupt benötigt
wird um so ein papier dann raus zu geben
das wissen es bei ihnen aus haben sie da
noch lange nicht
oberflächliche person wie auch die
geselligkeit und durch ihre insel
begabung gehe ich ja habe sich in
kleinen auf kleinen terror sehr sicher
fühlt und ihn kaum folgen konnte weil
ich aber weiß geht vielen so ist man
also lisa niemi us beschlüsse ich
schlafe ein dabei ich sage es ihnen
ehrlich ich verstehe ich es strengt mich
an ich kriege es auch nicht bezahlt
warum soll ich mich da wo andere leute
ist eh besser wissen und können ich nehm
ich bin ein bürger der im alltag die
dinge er spürt und ich werde meine maske
auch weiter tragen denn man kriegt
dadurch weniger andere krankheiten und
keine grippe und ich muss keine
autogramme geben ich werde nicht erkannt
ich fühle wird armin luhmer mit maske
große sonnenbrille und pudelmütze ich
bin selten in meinem leben so glücklich
unterwegs gewesen das behalte ich bei
ohne pudelmützen pflicht auch ohne
sonnenbrillen pflicht wobei wir seit
heute ja zum glück wieder die
sonnenbrille tatsächlich brauchen in
deutschland also dass tatsächlich die
nachricht des tages danke für den moment
désirée nick und hand und hals oder
jörges zwanzigster märz wird das datum
klingt nach der richtig gute nachricht
freedom day dann auch endlich endlich in
deutschland nachdem muss dass so viele
europäische staaten längst vorgemacht
haben aber es kommt halt reichlich spät
und ist es nur das was die regierung
tatsächlich tun muss